it's the screen junkies show one-year
extravaganza featuring Nick Mundy
cinemasins
how it should have ended Alison Haislip
the Annoying Orange schmoes no Jeremy
Jones the nostalgia critic DJ Flula
Superman and many more hey guys can you
believe it it's the one-year anniversary
of the screen junkies show we've done it
all we've interviewed celebrities from
Christopher Walken to Cobra Commander we
drove over two hours away to go to
comic-con with so many fans of the show
you know what I wanted to take it to the
streets and see what the people on the
streets of Hollywood have to say about
our one-year anniversary are you guys
excited about the screen junkies show
one-year anniversary
never heard of it haven't seen it I
don't know screen junkies I have no idea
what that is I don't know are you a fan
of Hal Rudnik who's that I don't know
who that is either who's hell Rudnick
doesn't even ring a bell oh I don't know
who that is I don't know who is
thank you sir okay well that was a dose
of reality we asked you what you wanted
to see in our one-year anniversary show
and the response was overwhelming and
one of the most requested things is
summed up here I want to see Nick Mundy
raging about Ben Affleck being the new
Batman well we tried to contact Nick
Monday and apparently he's who's at the
door
Nick Mundy made it thanks for coming by
Nick yeah it's about time it's been a
while so Nick could you fulfil that fans
request and rant about Ben Affleck as
Batman because okay Zack Snyder okay and
then and the Ben Affleck I mean honestly
it's probably gonna be pretty good the
movie has plenty of problems already Ben
Affleck is not gonna make it worse
I mean he's not my first choice I do
have one person who I think would be the
ultimate Batman don't say it it's the
rock the rock would be the best Batman
you know the rock tweeted at me we're
buddies you tell me that every time you
see me the rock Hercules me and you fast
seven let's do it next summer
Nick Monday everybody so a lot of you
requested that I jump off a high
building right onto concrete that's not
gonna happen
but a number of you suggested something
else bring cinemasins guy for the
anniversary we reached out and the folks
at cinemasins were awesome enough to
give us this
show house extremely hairy arms more
than two copies of mr. and mrs. Smith on
the never changing adopted direwolf
poster not an honest trailer
congratulating another channel on the
anniversary of their web series cliche
guys this is almost better than getting
free Chipotle I mean what else could
happen who's here now ma he'll help your
anniversary thanks Hollywood Superman
Chris Dennis it's so awesome that you're
here and as a matter of fact there were
a number of requests bring back creepy
Superman picking up girls in a limo
remember when we went out in that limo
and we met some cool ladies and you
started to get pretty friendly with one
she gave you her number
yep what happened I tried to read the
number that was written down and I
couldn't quite make out a few of the
numbers well lucky for you we actually
have her number on the form she filled
out we can call and see how she's doing
let's do it hi
it's Hal Rudnick from the screen junkies
show I'm here with Superman say hi hi we
were calling to see if you wanted to
hang out can you say happy anniversary
screen junkies show thank you bye bye
Superman I actually have to reveal
something that wasn't really the girl
from that night we're not that creepy
you guys it was our friend Muriel that
was outside the room and he called thank
you the creepiness had dissipated and
then it went right back up thanks
Superman
you never disappoint wow this shows
better than my bar mitzvah I'm having
the time of my life who could be at the
door now Alison Haislip one of my
favorite people to have on the show
one-year anniversary so I wanna stop by
and say congrats I decided to do
something special for you I talked to
the producers and I found your most
embarrassing deleted scene and now we're
gonna show it to everyone you don't get
to watch that's good so this is you in
your mom watching Human Centipede yes
nice mother-son activity for Mother's
Day obviously yes but you look kind of
weirdly nervous how why are you so
nervous because I desperately need to
urinate Alison hey guys is there any way
we could pause okay okay look at that
look at those scratchy fingers fingers
let's look at my eyes all right you
pause it for a sec I oh I have to really
have to go to the bathroom oh sorry
sorry I'm thoroughly embarrassed thanks
for being so good to us and coming on
the show
Alison Haislip everybody Wow guys I'm
seriously having more fun than the time
that dentist gave me too much drugs
who's here now Hey no mark and Draco the
writer of Manhunter and bat woman so
here it's the first anniversary of
screen junkies and I wanted to come by
and say congratulations you know this
yeah you're coming by so it's read that
how I work in a world of superheroes
right it is rare for me to encounter
someone as super as you I don't want to
read this this is - there's a lot more
and happy Anniversary now here are some
congratulations from some real people
for you hey Mark it's screen junkies
one-year anniversary hard to believe
it's been 365 days and they still
haven't found a better replacement for
how Congrats how does it do this
this hurts hey Daniel screen junkies is
a year old
so is everyone else congratulations
screen junkies
happy Anniversary Congrats on one year
at the screen junkies show what if
screen junkies were good like really
good oh wow scream junkies one here oh
it's so amazing great oh yeah and thanks
for firing me also yeah
hey guys from all of us here at homemade
movies Congrats on your 10 year
anniversary
what Oh on your 1 year anniversary
all right after 1 year I would like to
say a big thank you to Hollywood because
they've been pumping out trailers that
make movies look better than they
actually are for years and without that
we would not appreciate screen junkies
and their honors trailer segments
seriously though your honest trailer
segments never give that up ever because
I need it
being a nostalgia critic I'm of course
blown away by all the stuff that screen
junkies does of course there was that
one time we did that honest trailers of
Batman and Robin and you mentioned that
a little bit of plastic that's what rubs
me the wrong way I always said that no
other human being should ever mention it
of course it's the back hey hey guys
just wanted to say congratulations on
the one-year anniversary yeah congrats
al for being the only person more
annoying than me hi al this is mo
Mattoon congratulations on making one
year on screen junkies but I wish you
would spit onto me we had a special day
but I'm a married woman now so take the
hint hint baby goodbye a sugar mama June
I could make you a very happy woman I
know most of you think that I am a very
powerful one-man gang and that is true
in some respects but there are a lot of
people over the course of this year that
have helped make screen junkies show and
I want to bring in a lot of them come on
in everybody
Dennis Alison Haislip dan Merle our
editor Mitch rod or oh just thanks that
powerful man oh this guy I want to thank
you guys for watching I want to thank
everybody here for doing the awesome
things that you do and I'm Hal Rudnick
has anyone seen Bruce Willis this happy
in decades the guy needs to start
drinking the wine coolers again look at
him he's going crazy
loves it he's singing oh man start
drinking the wine coolers again Bruce